qu'on parle de broussailles mais dans
des dizaines de pays l'homosexualité est
encore considéré comme un crime oui
c'est l'idée d'ailleurs dans certains
pays c'est même passible de la peine de
mort il ya deux régions vraiment du
globe sur lequel cette peine de mort est
concentré c'est d'abord en afrique à
quatre pays là bas qui sont capables
d'appliquer cette peine de mort en cas
d'homosexualité donc la mauritanie le
nigeria la somalie le soudan et l'autre
régions de la planète et bien on parle
ici de l'asie du sud et du moyen-orient
où là il y a pas mal plus de pays qui
ont décidé d'aller de l'avant avec la
peine de mort l'afghanistan par exemple
l'arabie saoudite l'iran la syrie
surtout lorsque c'était le groupe armé
état islamique qui régnait là-bas
pakistan qatar et au yémen ce qui fait
que lorsqu'on on comptabilise le nombre
de pays dans lesquels l'homosexualité
est répréhensible
eh bien on arrive au chiffre de 76 et à
différents quand même c'est assez
beaucoup depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant il ya de plus en plus de pays
qui décident d'aller vers la
dépénalisation
c'est le cas par exemple bon on va
d'abord regarder donc douze pays qui ont
qui vont jusqu'à la peine de mort il a
soixante particulièrement en afrique qui
décident d'emprisonner les personnes qui
sont coupables d'homosexualité et il y
aussi des lois qui ont été créés des
lois de propagande contre
l'homosexualité par exemple ya trois
pays dont la russie la lituanie mais
aussi le cas de la russie voilà est donc
maintenant l'homosexualité dépénaliser
dans pas moins de 124 pays
il ya quand même une forte tendance vers
cette dépénalisation l'inde par exemple
l'a fait il ya quelques mois de cela les
autres pays récent baer il ya par
exemple le mozambique le liban le
nicaragua ou encore le panama alors
pourquoi ça s'accélère ben c'est quand
même assez récent le fait que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
décidée elle de retirer de la liste des
maladies mentales l'homosexualité et ça
c'était seulement en 1990 ça veut dire
que tu à peine trente ans que l' oms a
décidé de retiré l'homosexualité de
cette fameuse liste
bon évidemment il ya plusieurs pays dont
le canada qui vont beaucoup plus loin
que la dépénalisation en légalisant le
mariage entre conjoints de même sexe
voilà exactement donc rapidement il ya
26 états qui l'ont fait majoritairement
européens ce sont les pays bas qu'il en
fait la première fois en 2001 le canada
ici c'était en 2005 et enfin il ya un
pays qui ment ce qui mérite une mention
c'est l'afrique du sud
qui a accepté les mariages entre
conjoints de même sexe en 2006 pourquoi
on le mentionne parce que c'est le seul
pays africain qui a décidé d'aller aussi
loin que ça merci frais car vous en prie